I think it's time to switch things up a bit and see some numbers that can't be
written as rational powers of the base. We're also going to pick a new base to
work with, log base 10, which is one of the most convenient bases to use
because there's a button on calculators for it. In fact, I'd like you to use
your calculator to do these problems. You'll probably be able to figure out a
few of them on your own without the calculator, but it makes sense to use it
just to make sure that the buttons work the way you think they do. In fact, on
many calculators and sometimes in textbooks and other places, instead of seeing
log base 10. You'll just see the word log without a base written, this usually
means log base 10. In fact, let's look and see what my calculator has on it.
Sure enough, there's just a button that says log with no base. This is log base
10. So let's say I want to find log base 10 of some number. Well, 11 is my
favorite number as you know, so let's try that. You can see I press log, and
then enter the number that I'm looking for. Close the parentheses for good
measure and press equals and there we go, a long decimal. I'm going to try
another just to humor myself. How about log base 10 of 2,314? Why not? There we
go. So here are a bunch of log base 10 problems for you to figure out. I'll
demo one on the calculator just to make sure that it's working like we think
it's going to. To find log base 10 of 1 if I didn't want to use the calculator,
I'd rewrite 1 as 10 to the 0. So that means this should give us 0. Let's make
sure our calculator's working the way we think it is. So to find log base 10 of
1, I press log and then 1. Close the parentheses and sure enough we got 0.
Great. Now you get plenty of chances to try this out on your own.